[Música]
son estos quién demonios los ha tomado
al menos una vez en su vida una taza de
café seguro seguro que todos
absolutamente todos los que nos estáis
viendo habréis consumido este producto
en alguna ocasión y luego claro están
las personas que como me pasa a mí nos
pasamos el día enganchados a esta
placentera y revitalizante bebida os
imaginais empezar el día sin una buena
taza rebosante por la mañana yo no el
café se ha convertido en un producto
global que nos vamos a poder encontrar
en prácticamente cualquier rincón del
mundo ahora bien nunca os habéis
preguntado qué hay más allá de vuestra
humeante taza de café queridos amigos
amigas en este vídeo os vamos a contar
cuáles son los principales detalles
cuáles son las principales
características y los retos de esta
apasionante industria un mercado del que
no se habla mucho pero que sin embargo
es uno de los más grandes del mundo por
volumen de transacciones económicas cada
vez se consume más y más café
[Música]
ya lo veis no hablamos ni mucho menos de
una industria precisamente pequeña
durante el 2020 el negocio del café
movió más de 450 mil millones de dólares
estás preparado para adentrarte con
nosotros en este apasionante mundo que
nos acompaña cada mañana además en esta
ocasión vamos a poder escuchar también
la experiencia de écija una empresa que
se dedica a la financiación colaborativa
de productores de café fueron ellos que
nos dieron la idea de preparar este
vídeo arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la industria cafetera es quizás una de
las más desconocidas de todas las
grandes industrias del mundo por ejemplo
latinoamerica produce el 70 por ciento
de la producción mundial de granos de
café al tiempo que los 6 mayores
productores del mundo son brasil vietnam
colombia indonesia honduras y etiopía
luego entre los 10 mayores productores
encontramos también a perú guatemala y
méxico hasta aquí ninguna sorpresa
verdad todos ellos son países de renta
baja con importantes bolsas de pobreza
principalmente en las zonas rurales sin
embargo junto a brasil colombia y
vietnam en el top 6 de los mayores
exportadores nos encontramos a suiza
alemania e italia no hay algo que os
llama la atención
exacto en el mercado del café los
mayores productores no son siempre
quienes más dinero ingresan con las
exportaciones cafeteras y eso eso a
pesar de que este cultivo necesita de
unas condiciones climáticas muy
específicas como un determinado tipo de
suelo o de temperatura de
precipitaciones o de altitud sobre el
nivel del mar es decir que se cultiva
café donde se puede cultivar café lo que
en principio debería darle a los
productores un mayor poder de mercado
pero claro para entendernos podríamos
decir que la bolsa de café que podemos
comprar todos
mercado sería algo así como el
equivalente a una camiseta de algodón en
una tienda de ropa mientras que el café
que se recoge en colombia sería como el
algodón recién salido de la flor y claro
entre ambos productos existe un intenso
proceso de transformación y aportación
de valor y también por supuesto entre
ambos es donde aparece el marketing
luego veremos por qué esto es importante
pero antes antes para empezar echemos un
vistazo al caso de suiza suiza es el
segundo país del mundo que más ingresa
gracias a las exportaciones de café
hablamos de casi 3 mil millones de
dólares a pesar de que en el país alpino
no hay plantaciones de café sus
exportaciones cafeteras superan incluso
a las de colombia lo que resulta mucho
decir especialmente si tenemos en cuenta
que en el país latinoamericano trabajan
en el sector más de 700 mil personas y
el país produce cada año más de 14
millones de sacos de 60 kilogramos un
tipo de medidas estos sacos que vienen a
ser al café lo que el barril es al
petróleo pues bien la cuestión es que si
te importa café sin tostar esto es al
grano tal y como sale del campo pero no
es que luego son tostados empaquetados y
vendidos de emilio en formas diferentes
y es en esta diferencia en la
transformación de un producto primitivo
en un producto final donde se crea valor
y el café multiplica su precio esa es
exactamente la razón por la que el país
helvético genera tanto negocio
exportando café sin tener plantaciones
de este grano en empresas como la suiza
nestlé que es el tercer mayor importador
privado de café transforman el primitivo
grano salido por ejemplo de brasil en
productos tan habituales en la vida
diaria de los países desarrollados como
son las
expresó
y es justo aquí donde se encuentra la
clave que convierte al café en un
negocio muy pero que muy lucrativo y lo
que explica que los agricultores del
café en muchos casos no vean ni una
centésima parte del precio al que
finalmente se vende su producción al
consumidor
[Música]
pero antes de que alguno empieza a
culpar a los malvados capitalistas que
exprimen a los agricultores
lo cierto amigos es que todo tiene una
explicación y tras la explicación están
también las posibles soluciones hasta
qué punto los países productores se
aprovechan del enorme negocio mundial
del café cómo es posible que suiza tenga
un sector cafetero tan grande como el de
la mismísima colombia por volumen de
negocio pues bien veámoslo pero un
momento antes antes vamos a conocer a
nuestros amigos de eficaz
que han querido apoyar abisal político y
que tienen un proyecto que a nosotros
nos ha llamado mucho pero que mucho la
atención
apunte cuando terminéis de ver este
vídeo lo entenderéis todo mucho mejor y
ahora con vuestro permiso lanzó la
primera pregunta que es exactamente fija
para hombre muchas gracias a enrique
este hub es un proyecto de impacto
social muy ambicioso utilizamos la
tecnología block change para que
cualquier persona pueda financiar a
pequeños productores de café de calidad
extraordinaria pero que no tienen acceso
al sistema financiero tradicional qué
interesante gabriela personalmente este
tipo de proyectos me suenan fenomenal
esa idea de compaginar el ánimo de lucro
con impulsar el desarrollo no sé me
encanta pero por qué creéis que vuestro
modelo es mejor para la industria del
café pues yo creo enrique el sistema
tradicional del mercado del café está
obsoleto y acaparado por grandes
compañías que desfavorecen la
financiación y la calidad de los
cultivos de los pequeños agricultores
quienes a pesar de producir casi el 80%
del total mundial viven en condiciones
de pobreza etihad financia una cadena de
suministros más corta prescindiendo de
los intermediarios que no aportan valor
bien en este mismo vídeo vamos indagar
en todas estas cuestiones pero gabriela
hay una pregunta que es obligada qué
ventajas puede tener apostar por
a la hora de invertir con el hub formas
parte de una comunidad visionaria
disruptiva desde la comodidad de tu
ordenador puedes invertir desde veinte
euros y recibes a cambio un 8 por ciento
de rentabilidad anual
sumate athletic hub y cambia el mundo
con tu tasa de café
muchas gracias gabriela por vuestro
apoyo a la hora de montar este vídeo
dejamos el enlace a vuestra web en la
descripción para quien esté interesado
en conocer mejor nuestro proyecto y
ahora para todos vosotros replicó la
pregunta cómo es posible que suiza tenga
un sector cafetero tan grande como el de
la mismísima colombia por volumen de
negocio atentos
[Música]
la huella del café
amigos la industria del café ha cambiado
mucho las últimas décadas desde las
cápsulas hasta las máquinas de vending o
los starbucks la industria del café no
para de transformarse y cada vez de la
experiencia cuenta más sin embargo lo
que no ha cambiado tanto es la situación
de los principales países productores de
café no al menos por esta materia prima
[Música]
las regiones cafeteras siguen siendo en
muchos casos sinónimos de subdesarrollo
en concreto hablamos de unos 25 millones
de pequeños productores de café el 80%
de los cuales viven por debajo del
umbral de la pobreza una industria
millonaria asentada sobre la absoluta
miseria por ejemplo en colombia un país
que exhala café por sus cuatro costados
las exportaciones cafeteras apenas
suponen el 0 7 por ciento de su economía
y en brasil el mayor productor mundial
apenas el 0 3%
[Música]
dicho de otra forma el café es más
lucrativo para la economía suiza que
para la mismísima colombia' de locos
pero entonces la pregunta es qué
demonios pasa aquí qué problemas tienen
los países productores porque países
como colombia honduras o brasil son
incapaces de explotar esta enorme fuente
de riqueza pues principalmente podemos
destacar tres grandes obstáculos en
primer lugar está el tamaño de los
productores y es que veréis entre el 70
y el 80 por ciento de todo el café que
se produce en el mundo lo producen
pequeños agricultores a través de
minifundios de pequeñas plantaciones y
esto que a priori a muchos de vosotros
os puede parecer un dato poco relevante
y a otros muchos incluso un escenario
que evoca el activismo y romanticismo
social ahí esos pequeños agricultores
saliendo adelante con sus propias manos
trabajando el campo mañana tarde y noche
resulta clave para explicar por qué el
café es más lucrativo en suiza- que en
colombia
[Música]
la inmensa mayoría de esos 25 millones
de pequeños productores de café se
encuentran en zonas rurales y
empobrecidas de países que ya de por sí
son bastante pobres es decir hablamos de
productores y medios económicos
suficientes como para invertir en bienes
de capital como por ejemplo tractores
con los que mejorar la productividad de
sus plantaciones o desarrollar modelos
de negocio más complejos es la
pescadilla que se muerde la cola no
tener recursos les impide desarrollarse
ya no desarrollarse no tienen los
recursos que necesitan para prosperar y
mejorar su nivel de vida y justo aquí
encontramos el segundo gran problema al
que se enfrentan los pequeños
agricultores del café si uno de estos
agricultores o varios de ellos quisieran
por ejemplo montar su propia planta de
tostado y procesamiento necesitarían
enormes cantidades de dinero es decir
tendrían que pedir un préstamo o buscar
un inversor problema tal y como vimos en
el vídeo sobre cómo se malogró el perú
en estos países los mercados financieros
están muy pero que muy poco
desarrollados de tal forma que conseguir
un préstamo para un agricultor es casi
una tarea imposible y de hacerlo se
enfrentaría además a tipos de interés
que pueden superar incluso el 40 por
ciento anual
[Música]
así que resumiendo no tienen dinero para
crecer al no crecer no pueden prosperar
y al no prosperar no pueden acceder a un
préstamo y así una y otra vez para colmo
y este es el tercer gran problema al no
desarrollar actividades más complejas
los pequeños agricultores quedan
totalmente expuestos a las variaciones
de precios que se producen en el mercado
internacional por ejemplo cuando hay una
buena cosecha o cuando las plantaciones
se incrementan puede ocurrir que los
agricultores vean hundirse los precios
incluso muy por debajo de su coste de
producción fijaos por ejemplo en este
gráfico para ver lo volátil que resulta
el precio del café
[Música]
y la pregunta es cómo demonios se puede
escapar de esta especie de círculo
vicioso
[Música]
pues aquí podemos encontrar al menos dos
posibilidades una podría ser fomentar la
agrupación de los agricultores de café
en cooperativas de modo que entre ellos
puedan formar un ente más grande que
seas y capaz de acceder más fácilmente a
tecnología formación mejores acuerdos
comerciales o financiación incluso ha
llegado el caso podrían apoyarse entre
sí pero claro aún así hablamos de
castillos en el aire
bueno castillos nunca mejor dicho para
estos pequeños agricultores que en
muchos casos no saben leer ni escribir
desarrollar organizaciones más complejas
no resulta algo tan sencillo y además se
necesita de la participación de muchos
productores productores que no siempre
pueden cambiar su actividad tradicional
porque viven al día si le venden un
comprador le tienen que seguir vendiendo
para poder comer un embrollo para colmo
tampoco se resuelve la otra gran
cuestión incluso para formar entes
empresariales o cooperativas hace falta
dinero en esta misma línea en algunos
países como es por ejemplo el caso de
colombia existen instituciones que han
tratado de hacer frente a este problema
fijaos
[Música]
en colombia existe la federación
nacional de cafeteros un ente nacido en
1927 que a través del llamado fondo
nacional del café asegura la compra de
toda la producción de sus miembros a
precios de mercado esta entidad que
opera por mandato del gobierno
colombiano funciona a través de una red
compuesta por 36 cooperativas y más de
500 puntos de compra repartidos a lo
largo y ancho de todo el país gracias a
su mayor poder de negociación en el
mercado
la federación logra precios
sustancialmente mayores a los que
lograría un pequeño campesino hablamos
de importes que pueden llegar a ser un
40 o incluso un 50% más altos cada año
estas cooperativas gestionan más del 30
por ciento de toda la producción
colombiana
el problema es que aunque ha sido muy
útil al final en muchos casos se ha
manifestado como un instrumento
insuficiente porque pues porque le ha
garantizado así a los pequeños
agricultores la compra de su producción
pero no han ido mucho más allá al final
este tipo de entidades tan grandes
burocráticas y poco expuestas del
mercado tienen limitaciones y la mejor
prueba es que tras 75 años de vida esta
federación dio el salto y puso en marcha
la cadena de cafeterías juan valdez para
tratar así de incrementar el valor
generado por los productores colombianos
ya tienen más de 120 establecimientos
repartidos por todo el mundo es algo así
como el auténtico rival colombiano de
starbucks seguro que ahora entendéis por
qué esa marca utiliza el lema el café de
todo país
en cualquier caso amigos es aquí donde
surge la segunda posibilidad que sería
la de poder acceder a microcréditos
colaborativos un instrumento que poco a
poco ha ido cobrando más y más peso y en
qué consiste en estos microcréditos pues
en préstamos pequeños que se entregan
sin necesidad de tener un aval y con
tipos de interés de mercado sí pero
mucho más ajustados con ellos un pequeño
agricultor puede comprar más tierras
comprar un tractor comprar máquinas
etcétera etcétera de esta forma pueden
escapar del círculo vicioso acceden a
recursos con los que pueden crecer
al crecer mejorar su nivel de vida y
entonces reintegrar los préstamos le
hemos dado una vuelta al problema y este
este es el motivo por el que los
microcréditos colaborativos que están
creciendo tanto en los países
subdesarrollados
[Música]
amigos impulsar este tipo de fórmulas
podría contribuir a reducir mucho la
pobreza especialmente en américa latina'
y es que no sólo hablamos de los más de
25 millones de pequeños productores que
hay en el mundo sino de millones y
millones de personas más que podrían
mejorar sus vidas por la mejora de las
economías locales en las zonas rurales
de países como méxico brasil colombia
honduras o guatemala
es decir en otras palabras para mejorar
la vida de los agricultores del café y
convertir a esta industria en un motor
de riqueza no hace falta menos mercado
sino todo lo contrario pero llegados
hasta aquí turno para ti te habías
parado a pensar en lo que hay detrás del
café que te tomas cada mañana cuál crees
que sería la mejor fórmula para mejorar
la vida de los millones y millones de
personas que se dedican a plantar este
cultivo déjanos tu respuesta por aquí
abajo en los comentarios y como siempre
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
abisal politics si aún no lo has hecho
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]